bonjour thomas cette déclassification
doit donc permettre de revenir sur un
chapitre particulièrement sensible
évidemment entre la france et l'algérie
la décision pourtant était attendue par
les universitaires de longue date qui
souhaitaient se pencher justement sur
ces questions mémorielles autour de la
guerre d'algérie notamment
oui il faut dire que jusqu'à présent
leur travail était particulièrement
fastidieux à cause de toutes ces
procédures de tous ces dispositifs
législatifs qui rase ralentissait
considérablement le désarrimage depuis
septembre deux recours avaient été
déposés devant le conseil d'état contre
une circulaire qui oblige à déclassifier
chaque document avant communication une
procédure que même l'elysée reconnaît
comme laborieuse alors les appels
répétés des chercheurs et des historiens
ont finalement été entendus puisque
dorénavant les archives pourront être
déclassifiés par cartons entiers par les
services des archives nationales et du
ministère des affaires étrangères un
allègement administratif qui va donc
permettre d'aller plus vite dans les
procédures même si l'elysée indique
engagé un travail législatif d'ici l'été
pour permettre un meilleur accès aux
archives sans pour autant compromettre
la sécurité nationale
alors thomas concrètement quels sont les
archives qui seront accessibles et bien
les documents internes que l'état a pu
produire sur une période allant jusqu'à
1970 soit l'année du départ du dernier
soldat français d'algérie ces documents
pourraient par exemple concerner les
disparus de la guerre ils sont estimés
au nombre de deux mille deux cents selon
alger selon un conseil de l'elysée un
conseiller de l'elysée cité par l afp
c'est une masse colossale d'archivés qui
repose dans des milliers de cartes on
parle même de plusieurs kilomètres de
cartons qui serait en ce moment
entreposés dans les archives et cette
déclassification s'inscrit dans une
politique plus large évidemment de
travail mémoriel entre la france et
l'algérie
oui c'est un souhait d' emmanuel macron
et l'elysée indique qu'il veut aller
très vite sur ce dossier le 20 janvier
dernier vous l'avez dit l'historien
benjamin stora a remis son rapport il
recommandait notamment cette avancée en
ce qui concerne les archiver dans sa
volonté de réconciliation mardi dernier
macron a également reconnu la
responsabilité française dans
l'assassinât de l'avocat indépendantiste
ali boumendjel en 1957 un geste salué
par alger mais les autorités algériennes
demande plus aksas et peu convaincu par
le rapport stores alger réclame l'accès
à l'ensemble des archives de la période
coloniale il heureux il regrette aussi
le fait que les informations sur les
essais nucléaires menés par la france
dans le sahara algérien dans les années
resteront secrètes et puis si emmanuel
macron et son homologue algérien abdel
madjid ed boon se sont engagé un travail
conjoint sur la question mémorielle il
reste encore des divergences alger
souhaite par exemple la reconnaissance
par la france de ce qu'elle présente
comme des crimes coloniaux paris de son
côté exclu jusqu'à maintenant de
présenter des excuses
merci beaucoup thomas pour ces
précisions et la question d'âme et moi
on va continuer d'en parler dans un
instant